Dillons with us in Greensboro North
Carolina
hi Dylan how are you I'm wonderful Dave
Harry better than I deserve what's up to
kind of go along with what you were just
saying about housing well I'll start by
saying that my dad has done everything
for me I currently live in his house
with my family of four he just moved in
with his new wife at her house he was
paying bills and mortgage and everything
for me until he lost his job in 2016 I
took on everything at once and basically
with the 40 grand I made per year at
that time I paid some of the stuff and
charged the rest to credit mm-hmm so the
other day well my plan this whole time
was to pay off the house the rest of the
way
fix it up and then either rent it out or
you know let my dad sell it at a later
point the other day I had a night I'm
sorry it's your dad's house right so why
are you fixing up his house well I was
thinking at first you know that it might
be a place that I'd be fine with living
and you know he now that he's married
and living with his new wife he doesn't
he doesn't I guess you need the house
for anything so he wants to sell homes
they want you to murder no I'm trying to
I'm trying to change things up to help
you know my position in his position so
what I was thinking was that if we sold
the house for what it's worth now I
could use some of the money from that to
see her house I now get the money when
you sell his house
hello yeah I'm still here he like that's
why I started with he's done everything
he can for me
and he's trying to help me get out of
credit debt that I'm in now he's gonna
give him his house
well not all of it I'm not I'm not
asking for you no I'm not asking for any
of it but he's good I think you need to
move out and rent and get on a budget
and take enough jobs to pay for your
family and let your dad do what he wants
to do with his house this is a pretty
dysfunctional codependent relationship
you're a grown man with a family and
your daddy's still taking care of you
dude it's time to get your game up
that's what it sounds like to me this is
the Dave Ramsey show